China is expected to play a big role in
potential meetings
north Korea has with South Korea and the
United States representatives from the
North and South planned to meet tomorrow
to discuss their upcoming summit South
Korean president moon jae-in
and North Korean leader Kim jong-un will
attend the first bilateral meeting
between the two nations in more than a
decade on April 27 the White House is
also moving forward with plans for
president Trump to meet Kim jong-un a
time and place have not been anounced
the New Yorkers Evan Osnos covered and
covers North Korea and travelled there
last summer good morning let's start can
we start with China for a minute we're
in the middle of despite what the
president says this back and forth with
China at the State Department they were
saying we need China the president used
to say we need China in these
negotiations with North Korea so how can
the u.s. be both in a fight with them
over trade and also needing them or do
they not need them in these negotiated
and traditionally this is why diplomats
try to keep these things in separate
buckets because you say you don't want
the success or failure of one issue to
impact the other at the moment what
they're trying to do is say look let's
make sure that China knows that we're
altima trying to seek a negotiation on
trade but let's not complicate the
biggest national security issue we have
what is your assessment of North Korea
and their posture are they engaged in
these in talks in some kind of
good-faith way or is there another play
here well their heads are spinning as
much as they are here in Washington and
in New York look the North Koreans spent
years decades being trained to believe
the United States was their enemy when I
was in North Korea last summer what I
discovered was that people were hearing
propaganda every day on the street on
billboards in schools kids are asking me
why it is that the Americans are trying
to stop them from developing a weapon
and now they're turning on a dime I
think this is sincere what's quite clear
when you talk to people inside North
Korea when you talk to people outside is
that they recognized they were on an
unsustainable path towards confrontation
with the United States so the question
is how can you defuse that and come up
with a more sustainable range you write
too about their impression about Donald
Trump there are people there whose job
is to stutter is to study his Twitter
feed what are they trying what are they
looking for what are they thinking about
that well they literally watch every
syllable that he says and what I
discovered when I was there is sort of a
surprise which is we thought well
maybe they've decided Donald Trump's
their enemy actually they hadn't they
had allowed themselves the possibility
that this man this author of the art of
the deal and they had read the book
because Dennis Rodman brought them we
brought the book yes and they thought
this might be the man who's going to sit
down with us at the negotiating table
and they were waiting for the moment
when the conditions were right and when
they were they they offered it but this
one man said to you that we're trying to
figure out is he either too irrational
or too smart they were genuinely unsure
they couldn't decide if he was playing
some complicated game insulting Kim Jong
on what they decided in the end was this
is a guy who deals in extravagant
flamboyant strokes he they knew he was
going to say things that were
over-the-top because those were the
opening rounds of a negotiation even
before they sat down to the tip and at
the same time as we're anticipating this
meeting of course all eyes are going to
be on Iran as well because they have the
recertification deadline coming up as
well many are expecting President Trump
to pull out of the Iran deal how closely
will Kim jong-un be watching what
happens in Iran and what implications if
any will it have on their negotiator it
does it cast a shadow over the
possibility for reaching some sort of
deal with North Korea North Korea is
trying to decide how much does Donald
Trump stand by not only the the words of
his predecessors but also the deals that
he makes while in office and if we pull
out of Iran that makes it harder you
also you also say that between the two
of them Evan I think this is interesting
they've got eight years of experience
and these very key roles so and both of
them want to prove to the other you know
I'm bigger than you
does it matter it must matter where this
meeting is going to be held
absolutely the coreography of this the
stage setting is tremendously important
could they have it in the United States
could they have an MPO yang most likely
if you had to put a bet down today it
will be someplace on neutral territory
it could be in Europe or it could be at
the DMZ between South Korea what does
Pyongyang need if they're going to be
asked to give up their nuclear program
which is a big ask the biggest thing
they want is some sort of reassurance of
their own survival meaning that they
don't want to be on a path towards
confrontation with the world's most
formidable military there's a lot of
steps that they could look to but that's
the key and that's the key thing so they
also say if they go to war they're ready
absolutely they've spent years preparing
for it they take this very seriously so
does the rest of the world
every nos nos always good to have you at
the table something tells me you'll be
back thanks a lot